bonjour pauline revers merci beaucoup
d'être avec nous ce matin en direct sur
rt france on sait que les agriculteurs
ont beaucoup de travail le matin donc
merci nous accorder quelques minutes il
n'y a pas de salon de l'agriculture
cette année néanmoins vous vous ne
lâchez pas la faire bonjour et merci
merci de me recevoir
donc en effet il n'ya pas de salon amis
à paris mais nous on est aussi impactée
par le salon agricole qui qui se faisait
à table la semaine après le salon de
paris où on accueilli quand même 65
mille visiteurs sur sur la ville de
tarbes et donc du coup mais on voit là
c'était un événement de grande ampleur
et on s'est dit qu'on pouvait pas rester
juste avec cette crise couve idc
annulation de salon sans répondre mais à
la demande du grand public de pouvoir d
justement être plus proche des
agriculteurs et pouvoir communiquer avec
nous du coup on a créé un salon virtuel
sur assurent les pyrénées alors un
symbole virtuel pour mieux connaître
votre profession une profession saluée
par les autorités
en pleine crise sanitaire pourtant c'est
un métier difficile de faibles revenus
dans quel état d'esprit sont les jeunes
agriculteurs aujourd'hui
alors aujourd'hui
oui c'est un métier où on cherche on
cherche à aller de l'avant
on cherche à revaloriser à nos
productions on cherche à aller chercher
du revenu car clairement les filières
aujourd'hui ne nous permettent pas
d'avoir un revenu suffisant
c'est aussi pour ça que vous avez dû
voir sur les dernières semaines les
agriculteurs se battaient aussi par
rapport à la loi et galim technique de
la fresque qui n'est pas appliquée qui a
été votée depuis novembre 2018 et qui
n'est toujours pas appliquée donc on se
bat pour que cette loi soit appliquée
pour que des pénalités soit peu l'état
pénalise les grandes surfaces pour
qu'ils appliquent cette loi pour pour
que les marges reviennent enfin dans les
cours de ferme et que ça soit pas
toujours les agriculteurs et les
consommateurs qu'ils soient les derniers
à les derniers pris en compte et qu'ils
soient toujours les premiers lésés est
ce que vous avez eu une réponse de la
part du gouvernement alors les
négociations se sont terminées
aujourd'hui on n'a pas de retour encore
peut-être qu'au niveau national les
retours commencent à arriver nous au
niveau départemental on n'a pas encore
de retour
par contre on peut voir que au moins une
enseigne de notre département ne joue
toujours pas le jeu voire même depuis
qu'on s'est exprimée a préféré avoir une
politique de retrait des produits locaux
donc on va continuer à se battre pour
pour dénoncer ça et pour pouvoir
répondre aussi aux attentes des
consommateurs aujourd'hui je pense que
les agriculteurs sont les premiers dans
la réponse aux attentes des
consommateurs et que ce sont nos
intermédiaires qui sont pas dedans alors
parmi ses attentes des consommateurs
justement il ya ce qu'on appelle le
localisme aller les politiques sont
lents par un justement de cette question
c'est ces derniers jours comme
agricultrice ce localisme vous pensez
que c'est la bonne voie c'est la bonne
solution du producteur au consommateur
directement je pense qu'il faut le
raisonner au niveau national parce que
tout simplement chaque région a ses
spécificités par le nom et dans le
sud-ouest si on compte que sur nos
productions ben on n'utilisera pas de
sucre chez nous parce qu'il nous faut
nos betteraviers pour pour avoir du
sucre et inversement donc il va falloir
qu'on le raisonne au niveau national
parce que au niveau national on est
capable de produire et d'être en
autonomie alimentaire sur le territoire
national alors après les consommateurs
vont chercher du local et certaines
productions se font un peu partout en
france ou au moins ont des oui on sait
qu'on a des spécificités on est plutôt
sur une région avec de l'élevage on est
capable d'approvisionner en local sur
tout ce qui est élevage mais on aura
besoin pour certains produits d'autres
régions de france
quelles sont les conséquences de cette
crise sanitaire sur votre métier on le
voit les légions on préfère maintenant
aller à la fin ils sont de plus en plus
nombreux quels sont les autres
conséquences pour vous alors je pense
que après des années d'agri bashing où
on a quand même été énormément dénigrer
ça fait quand même je pense que de façon
globale ça fait quand même plaisir aux
agriculteurs de voir
la population compte sur eux se
rappellent qu'ils existent le
gouvernement aussi à plusieurs reprises
a fait appel aux agriculteurs
et voilà ça nous rassure aussi sur le
fait qu on sait pourquoi on travaille on
sait qu'on est là pour nourrir la
population et je pense que c'est un
sentiment un peu de fierté par rapport à
notre métier moi je le dis tous les
jours on doit être fier de ce conflit et
au final cette crise même si
économiquement pour certaines
exploitations c'est très très compliqué
on pourra dire moralement ça nous permet
d'asseoir notre place dans la société on
sait pourquoi on est là
merci beaucoup pauline robert d'avoir
accepté de répondre à nos questions ce
matin dans la matinale de rtl france je
le rappelle vous êtes la présidente des
jeunes agriculteurs 65 ou de pyrénées